[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today when you
find yourself making when here's some
things that will tell you if you're
making a wrong decision okay
because
making a wrong decision around money
particularly like a car purchase or
house purchase or something of the some
other a big investment deciding to go
into crypto deciding to do something
stupid along you know getting out of
where you're getting ready to set
yourself back a decade by screwing up
by making a bad decision see we always
talk about wealth building and the
things to do to build wealth I don't
think we spend enough time probably on
how to
uh
stupid proof ourselves so we don't do
something stupid and offset all the good
work we did right
so one of the things I discovered about
me and turns out it's true of everyone
is that right before I right after I get
desperate
I get stupid
and right after I get stupid I get broke
you know what I'm saying there's a close
connection when you feel desperation
trapped
I and you start your language will tell
you that you're that way I was forced to
we had no choice buy a car never in the
history of human races have been true
you were not forced they did not have a
gun
they don't do car reverse carjackings it
doesn't happen right so it doesn't
happen so you weren't forced you or in a
desperate situation on transportation
and so you Justified a dumb butt
decision to go to The Tote The Note lot
and pay double for the car at a 28
interest rate because you and then say
but I was forced you weren't forced you
were just stupid
I've been stupid too
right I just explained it right after I
felt desperate and trapped okay and so
when listen to your language and if your
language is indicating a sense of being
trapped a sense that there is no other
options
and in your language to yourself in this
decision making or to your spouse who
you're trying to talk into this is
bizarre
then that tells you that you're getting
ready to screw up okay I'll give you
another example we run into George
every
property for rent
in x-town
is four thousand dollars a month make up
a number fill it in
you can't find them they don't exist
see these absolute hyperbole statements
are indications that you feel desperate
and stuck and so once you've decided
inaccurately that every property for
rent is four thousand dollars minimum in
this town
then you can justify buying something
you shouldn't be buying at a point in
your finances that you aren't ready to
buy you see what I'm saying yeah so when
you start making these fatalistic
absolute statements
that are that are overstated
then and when you say if it sounds
bizarre to you then that tells you
you're there and that was my that was my
question with my I I couldn't get it out
of my mouth fast enough in that last
call
because we've been looking for a
property in Texas for nine years
okay that's just weird no you haven't
or if you have you've got other issues
other than property looking takes you a
decade that it takes a decade in Texas
to find something to live in
that's just not true that's just that's
that smacks of weirdness and
uh desperation and you're getting ready
to make a mistake but what that leads to
then is I'm going to do a deal here that
I know I shouldn't be doing because for
nine years this is the only property see
the see the you know how that comes out
and I do that in my own head that's how
I recognize the drama queen it lives in
all of our heads and it's like you know
I'm so stuck rental prices are so high I
am forced to buy a house I can't afford
while I have six hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt well that's
just dumber and crap you know no it's
just not true okay not true and and so
oh the other one I love is um
our house has mold
our children will die if we stay here
and
the only property we can find to live in
is sixty percent of our take-home pay
these are our two options
death of our children or bankruptcy
these are two options because we forced
ourselves in desperation into this false
Narrative of fatalism
that I'm stuck and the only way out is
to go from one stupid horrible thing to
another stupid horrible thing and I'm
trying to justify it by saying it's the
only option you see what I'm doing oh
yeah and every time I do that in my head
I have lost
so much money
I just every time that fear-based
desperation leads you into that and and
I get the these are the actual calls I
get here you've heard them I'm getting
triggered Dave my PTSD is coming back
from the caller saying well there's no
used cars under 25 000 so we had to
finance one for 35 because what else are
you gonna do yeah you're just stuck I
mean because it's not not a used car
anywhere
all the used cars in America that's
right now 25 000. so when you start
making these over the top crazy but
statements what that states is not the
actual fact what it indicates is your
mindset is in desperation and stuck
fatally there's a whiny toddler inside
all of us we just want the new car just
admit it you want the shinier newer car
well yeah but admitting it would be
dealing with me and I don't want to deal
with me instead I would rather create
this false Narrative of the marketplace
is forcing me into doing things it's the
economy High interest rates it's just
ridiculous I mean it's forced me the
only way I could go to school was to go
four hundred thousand dollars of student
loan debt
it's the only way it's the only possible
other than joining the military but only
possible other than to say only other
than other than other oh my God but the
only part so now here I sit
and Biden won't forgive them and so I'm
screwed you know and now Sunday you have
to start paying payments again not
someday Sunday this coming Sunday
so but yeah but but every time you say
something with a bizarre set of
overstatement
that is indicating you're getting ready
to make a mistake because I've done this
I've done I'm not making fun of y'all if
you've done it I'm not even making fun
of our last caller I mean it was a
little bit hard to keep up but I mean I
but even even aside from that I she just
was stuck and I want this and so I and I
don't think I should be doing it it
feels wrong but I've got to justify it
with everything else out here all the
three-story buildings and above are not
safe uh they don't have licensed
contractors you know all these other
wild and crazy stories out here in there
to justify the move and again that's not
picking on her she's sweet lady she's
trying to figure it out I appreciate her
calling if you call I'll pick on you too
but I'm picking on me and the same thing
because I'll tell you man some of the
dumbest butt stuff I've ever done is
when I was in facing uh bankruptcy I got
stuck in that and I thought there's no
way out there's nothing I don't know
what to do and I lost so stinking much
money
uh I made Decades of income evaporate in
in single Strokes of the pen because I
was desperate stuck and fixated
and the one that goes with that also the
sister to it is greed and when you get
when you get all fired up and you're
like oh I'm gonna but if okay if the
system is broken
yeah and the millennial can't get ahead
then the millennial has to do something
that's completely different crazy
shortcut exactly I need a Tick-Tock life
hack which is nothing down real estate
velocity banking is what we all need
velocity we need we need high speed
stupidity
High stupidity on high speed stupidity
on caffeinated stupidity that's what it
takes in today's world Dave yeah but
it's so true most of the calls on the
show is someone saying hey I've got
option A and option b and they're both
terrible what do I do and we say have
you ever thought about option C or D no
there's a lot of that and it involves
you instead of a shortcut it involves
that's how you know let me help you no
is a possible answer no it looks like
the only car you can find that suits
your needs is 25 000 and you're broke uh
answers no
and it's a complete sentence
no
it's an interesting sound
two letters the silence that follows it
is definitely no
this is the Ramsey Show